SPEAKER: Adding support
for a new platform
feature in your app can be
a very repetitive process.
Many times you will
switch back and forth
between your code and a step by
step tutorial or documentation,
especially where you're
not familiar with the API.
That was the case when I
was implementing support
for App Links, in a sample
app back when Android
Marshmallow was released.
App Links is a neat
feature that lets
you verify a domain that is
listed in your activities
content filters.
From that moment
forward, whenever a user
clicks on a URL
containing this domain,
your app will open
automatically without showing
the disambiguation dialog.
I remember that in order
to make this API work,
I had to make many small changes
in different parts of my app,
which is why I was very curious
when I heard about the new App
Links assistant that is part of
the Android Studio 2.3 release.
Its promise-- to add App
Links support in your project
with just a few clicks
without leaving the IDE.
Let's see how that works out.
I found the perfect sample
app for my experiment
under Google/searchsamples
on Github.
It's a very bare
bones recipe app.
The main page doesn't
really do anything,
but there is also a content
provider with several example
recipes set up and ready to be
displayed in the detail page,
implemented in recipe activity.
All I need to do is
open the activity
and call Show Recipe,
passing it content
URI which matches a recipe
in the content provider.
Now, imagine that I'm also
running a website for my app,
and I'd like my users to
be able to share and open
links to recipes in the same
way, regardless of which device
they are using.
Let's see how long it takes to
implement this using the App
Links assistant.
You'll find the assistant
under the Tools menu,
and it shows up as a panel
on the right side here.
First step, I want to define
URL mappings in my app.
I will add just one to connect
recipe URLs to the detail
activity.
I just have to fill in my
website's host name, and what
path to match.
I'll use the path prefix recipe
to also capture any recipe ID
after the last path separator.
And I want to launch
the recipe activity.
The tool generates the
correct intent filter,
and adds it to my manifest.
I can even see a
preview of the changes
and check that the URL
I need will get matched
to the correct activity.
Step 2, add logic to the
activity to handle the URL.
I'll select the activity that I
specified in the previous step,
and some code gets added
to my uncreate method.
This is just to help you get the
necessary data from the intent.
But remember that it's up
to you to actually handle it
in your app.
In my case, I want to load
and show the correct recipe.
For that, I need the recipe
ID, which is the last path
part in the URL.
Now I'll just convert that to
a URI, pointing to my content
provider, and pass
it on to Show Recipe.
In some cases, such as this
one, when the activity's launch
mode is set to single
top, you will also
have to handle a
new intent delivered
to an already running
instance of the activity.
I will refactor the code I
just wrote into a new method
and code that from our
new intent as well.
Before I move on to configuring
App Links on my server,
I just want to check that
everything I configured so far
works on the device.
I'll just use the App
Links tester in step 4
to launch a URL pointing to the
grilled potato salad recipe.
It correctly launches my
app, and shows the recipe.
Great.
You might have
noticed that there's
a migration dialog that popped
up when I launch the URL.
Getting rid of it and
launching directly into the app
is the last part.
Let's proceed with step 3,
generating the digital asset
links file.
You'll need a few
details about your app,
such as the domain you're using
in your links, application
ID, and the signing config.
Most of these will normally
be pre-filled for you
so you can just click
the Generate button.
Now, you will need to place
this file under this path
on the domain that you control.
Please note that
this is where it's
the easiest to make a mistake.
The path must match exactly.
The well-known folder must be
under the root of the domain,
and the server must be using
a valid HTTPS certificate
to serve the file even if your
App Links are only using HTTP.
For testing my app, I'm
just using Github pages,
which gives me an easy way of
hosting my asset links file
with the correct
SSL certificate.
Let's test the sample
link again in step 4.
And the app launches, taking
me directly into the recipe.
No need to click through
a dialog this time.
That's App Links, fully added
to a sample app in just four
steps, without looking
at the documentation.
If you like the App
Links assistant,
or if you have any
feedback, please let us
know on our social channels.
Thanks for watching, and for
more Android studio videos,
click here.